how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe we're only a couple
of days away from one division
episode four where we are promised by
the cast
that we are going to get some actual
reveals but what are these reveals what
exactly does one division have in store
for us and what exactly are they going
to be setting the mcu
up for wanavision has certainly had many
easter eggs throughout each episode that
we've seen so far but it seems like
one eagle-eyed fan seems to have spotted
a very
very hidden x-men easter egg in one
division
and we're going to dive into it but
first want to thank harry's for
sponsoring this video
more on them later now we know that the
x-men or should i say the mutants are
making their way to the mcu
kevin feige mentioned the mutants at san
diego comic-con in 2019 and he also
mentioned the fantastic four
right along with them and kevin feige
has already announced that the fantastic
four are already in development at
marvel studios however the x-men
are going to come very differently
they're going to introduce mutants
individually before they become the
x-men team
which means we're going to start to see
the individual mutants on disney plus
and of course in the movies before they
get introduced as a team which means
they're going to start getting
introduced
in phase 4 phase 5 and beyond and it
looks like they're coming sooner than
later and as i mentioned we seem to have
spotted a very hidden easter egg in one
division now the eagle-eyed fan that
spotted this
out is reddit user capped motorcycle and
this started by examining the strucker
watch in one division episode 2 and then
going on and
examining all of the other clocks within
all of the premiere episodes
now this reddit user suggests that these
clocks contain a secret message
the theory is that the positions of the
clock hands can be translated into
letters through the flag
semaphore system and when looking at all
of the letters that the clocks would
make
combined they say x-men as you can see
on the screen the letters x
m e and n and the flag sum of four
system
do seem to line up with what each of
these clocks says
and if you combine them one clock says x
another m
another e and another n now some may
think this
is stretching a little bit but i think
it's stretching to say that this is
coincidental because i do not think that
this could be a mere coincidence let's
think about it what are the odds that
each clock that we see
in one division actually make up the
letters x-m-e-n
there is no way that's an accident and
if you consider the fact that fans have
been talking about one division setting
up the x-men for a very long time now
and the fact that there's a lot of
evidence to support this and a lot of
theories out there that make a lot of
sense it would make sense that they
would put a hidden x-men easter egg in
here
it just doesn't seem like a coincidence
wanda and her brother petro were
basically the first mutants of the
marvel cinematic universe
it all started with them and the mind
stone slash loki's scepter
hydra is the one who experimented on
them and awoken their powers and we know
that hydra is going to play
some part in one division we've already
seen two commercials for hydra so since
wanda was the first mutant of the mcu
and hydra is responsible for that
or at least responsible for awakening
her mutant genes there is a chance that
whatever is to come
in the next six episodes of one division
it could lead up to the introduction of
more mutants or the awakening of more
mutant genes inside of people within
the marvel cinematic universe again what
are the odds that each clock would
specifically say
all of the letters of the x-men the
chances of this being coincidental are
super super slim
and marvel does this all the time they
know what they're doing they know to put
these super hidden easter eggs in there
and the mind stone could be possible for
the awakening of
the mutant genes we'll touch on that in
a bit but first i want to thank harry's
for sponsoring this video if you're
looking to start the new year
off the right way harry's is a personal
care brand that has reinvented the way
you shave
in a premium hassle-free way and they
support a great cause as they give
one percent of their global sales to
non-profit organizations that provide
mental health care to men
in need take care of yourself this year
with harry's who i personally believe
have the best
shaving products the razer cartridges
have five blades in them which makes for
a super smooth and super close shave
and their handle is weighted and has a
texture rubber grip
and their foam shaving gel has natural
ingredients in it such as aloe vera and
cucumber which hydrates and refreshes
your skin which is great for people with
sensitive skin
you can redeem your trial set for just
three dollars when you go to harrys.com
cosmic wonder if you're looking for the
best shave of your life this will
definitely help you and it's also for a
good cause as well
the trial includes a razor a travel
cover for the razor and
shave gel and again it's just three
dollars for the trial kit when you go to
harrys.com
cosmic wonder now if we go to one of the
one division trailers and tv spots where
we see wanda
apparently messing with the mine stone
and there is some sort of an explosion
this explosion could be the mind stone
exploding i think that's what most
people think it is
including myself but if the power of the
mind stone awakened the gene inside of
her then it could awaken the genes
inside of other people perhaps the
people who were trapped in the town
remember strucker and hydra experimented
on many different people but wanda and
pietro were the only two people who
actually were affected by the stone and
became enhanced marvel recently came out
with a tie and book to the mcu and it
stated that the reason
that this was was because of their genes
it was their specific genetics that made
it possible for them to obtain
powers so that's pretty much proof at
this point that they have the x
gene and somehow the mind stone awakened
those genes inside of wanda and petro
if there's an explosion with the mind
stone or any other infinity stones for
that matter
we can assume that any person that comes
in contact with the explosion that has
that x gene within them will have it
awakened
and mutants will be born but remember it
all starts with wanda
and all of the infinity stones were
destroyed in avengers endgame
but somehow it seems like wanda has
managed to bring the mind stone back
and it looks like it will explode at one
point in time and this could
introduce the mutants this is a pretty
awesome easter egg discovered and some
great detective work by this reddit user
capped motorcycle let me know what you
think about this in the comments down
below is it an x-men easter egg or do
you think that somehow
it's a coincidence let me know down
below and don't forget to subscribe so
you don't miss out on any of the latest
one division videos or mcu videos
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me you